je vous emmène aujourd'hui à roland
garros pour vous présenter un smartphone
duo popo et partir de roland-garros il
voyait on est juste là au la regarder il
n'y a pas beaucoup de monde la journée
commence on va aller se faire des
matches on va parler de smartphones
j'avais plutôt pas mal
[Musique]
mais plutôt de roland-garros depuis le
toit du village regarder on est pas mal
là derrière vous avez le court suzanne
lenglen bellevue si on est vu surtout
roland il est vraiment pas mal derrière
sont en train de jouer au ballon
si vous voyez là juste moi malgré tout
les courts annexes ça joue de tous les
côtés et derrière vous avez le court
chatrier qui est juste là donc là on a
une vue qui juste top merci au pot pour
l'invitation ça permet de découvrir de
me mettre au tennis tout cas de le
regarder et de pouvoir vous parler
justement aujourd'hui du haut forez
noces dans la première chose au niveau
de l opow raynaud on va avoir à
l'arrière trois caméras vous avez une
caméra principale de 48 médiatique c'est
avec une ouverture de f
1.7 avec une stabilisation optique
deuxième caméra de 8 mégapixels c'est le
grand-angle avec une ouverture de f/2
points depuis la troisième c'était
l'objectif c'est celui là là le très
très grand avec une stabilisation une
syndication qui complètement ouf en fait
et là vous avez un autofocus laser
l'autofocus laser en fait il va vous
servir vraiment à venir faire le point
très très rapidement c'est vraiment
super bien et à l'arrière
ici c'est pas si vous le voyez bien on a
un tout petit trou et se trompent fait
correspond aux micros directionnels qui
avoue servir vraiment aller capter en
direct le son vous avez pour venir
complètement optimisé en termes de
l'audio là la petite bille c'est lorsque
vous posez votre smartphone à plat pour
qu'ils n'aillent pas frotter mais voyez
smartphones qui est très bien surtout
tout est complètement hyper bien
intégrés et avant vous avez cette
fameuse petite caméra laquelle ronde
requins qui est situé juste là 16
mégapixels ouverture de f 2.0 vous avez
un tout petit flash la lumière très
douce qui est là pour venir vraiment
vous aider lorsque vous allez venir
prendre des photos films et un petit
renfort hyper douce et parfumée trop
agressif donc ça c'est plutôt cool et si
vous regardez bien au niveau de la
fabrication est un truc assez
intéressant c'est que là vous avez votre
haut parleurs regardez il est situé
juste là le petit haut parleur et là
vous avez un trou alors en fait le trou
il va servir à faire passer le son du
haut parleur qui est la star d' éviter
de faire une encoche supplémentaires etc
[Musique]
le gros gros gros gros gros focus qui
effectivement sur ce smartphone en
termes de photos c'est vraiment le zoom
x 10 heures vous voyez là déjà lorsqu on
est comme ça en vous pour un bon ça
c'est un grand classique vous arriver
progressivement sur le x 2 vous avez
ensuite sur le x 6 en plus c'est hyper
son goût s'est stabilisé alors je sais
pas si vous avez l'habitude avec moi
mais dès que c'est pas stabilisé et ça
pardonne pas vous arriver sur le x 10
regardez salle hyper stabiliser c'est
vraiment hyper l'impression l'art j'ai
le grand angle silva cement berhad
surtout le détail au niveau du ciel avec
le hdr bien super beau travail logiciels
qui fait là dessus et reconnaissance de
scène on voyait de l'intelligence
artificielle derrière vous en douterez
et lorsque voulait s'appuyer ensuite
vous venez vous avez un gradient et vous
pouvez monter jusqu'à un zoom x 20 alors
là on zoome fabing je suis un zoom
hybride dire que c'est sûrement mon
analogie qui m'ont numérique avec l'ia
ça reconnaît qu'à du texte et là ça
bouge un peu plus un petit peu moins
stabilisés forcément de caunes aussi sur
du numérique mais je peux venir ajouté
yves un rendu qui est cool laissez cet
gt1 c'est donc là je le montre avec le
zoom x 20 au maximum en hybride
qu'est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que à
la sortie de smartphones ce qui va pas
tarder d'ici quelques jours d'ailleurs
on vous regardez cette vidéo il se peut
qu'ils sont déjà sortis eh bien vous
avez un zoom hybride x 60 x 60 alors
vous le dirais qu'est ce qu'on va faire
à 15 me bride pas 60 alors il ya un côté
un peu what the fuck comme on a pu voir
avec le huawei p30 pro vous allez venir
chercher hyper loin du détail c'est
assez rigolo c'est un peu gadget est en
tout cas ce qui me fait assez sourire là
dedans c'est que le pétrole trop un zoom
hybride fois 50e au port et no x 10 à un
zoom hybride faut 60 on a un petit 10
d'écart est ce que ces histoires d'hier
matin c'est moi qui ai le zoom qui va le
plus loin on est sur un zoom logiciel
par contre déjà ce qu'il est capable de
faire avec cent une fois 10 est juste
incroyable
je vous mets quelques clichés je vous
laisse regarder j'étais pris à roland
garros vous avez différents clichés 11
une fois un x 3 x 6 x 10 et grand angle
là vous me dire ce que vous en pensez à
vos commentaires j'ai fait ma canne
acheter
[Musique]
tmz
lenovo skylight n'ont pas fui kokang
canton shenzhen hong hong kong selon
l'insee du point de vue logiciel vous
avez pas mal de choses pour une hérédité
très sympa alors vous avez sur une photo
a déjà une belle tête de vainqueur là
dessus vous allez d'en modifier et là
vous avez pas mal de choses à leur bon
vous allez voir différents types de
filtres pourra venir apporter un peu de
couleurs ajouté du pl sur ce que vous
voulez au choix vous voir mais
évidemment recadrer l'amélioration
automatique et vous allez pouvoir
ajouter ensuite d éthique et ce qui est
marrant c'est que l'intelligence
artificielle reconnaît quand même
relativement bien les visages ça vous
permettra effectivement voiliers de
pouvoir mettre ce que vous voulez ça
vous fait rigoler des petites casquettes
tout ce que vous voulez ça c'est cool ça
marche bien vous pouvez venir dessiner
griffonné si vous le voulez aussi dessus
et vous avez un mode beauté qui assez
marrant et ce que j'ai trouvé qui est
assez rigolo là dessus alors vous pouvez
enlever d'état ça vous pouvez venir
corriger pas mal de petits détails
peuvent venir agrandir les yeux si vous
le souhaitez voilà moi je tousse c'est
pas hyper naturel suis pas très fan mais
ce qu'il ya c'est marrant c'est le
blanchiment des dents
regardez mes dents là il faut le
rapproche un peu ça vient vraiment faire
un saut à ypres abrite donc bon pourquoi
pas il est ajouté un fait
[Musique]
il pleut il pleut pas un coup il pleut
un coup il peut pas roland garros voyez
le le traitement est assez marrant d'un
point de vue logiciel on peut faire pas
mal de choses d'un point du matériel
c'est vraiment bien et je vous dis on
est vraiment dans cette volonté des
fabricants aller toujours plus loin au
niveau de la photo en bas coûts de façon
la photo avec le smartphone celle d
usage principal avec le fait d'avoir un
grand écran mais surtout on fait
beaucoup de photos et ça les marques
l'ont compris notamment au pot qui passe
un gros budget en recherche et
développement pour venir à voir des
innovations très intéressante le mot
nuit intéressant pourquoi parce qu'avec
le petit laser fait un focus hyper
rapide vous appuyez en une seconde la
photo est fait ce qui est valable avec
le réno x 10 est ce qui n'est pas mal
avec lorraine au standard qui mettra un
peu plus de temps pour mieux capturer
une photo en faible luminosité ou alors
en mode nuit autant qu aux relents
garros vous emmener avec moi faire un
petit tour la sceller le côté vip loge
de haut qu on va aller faire un petit
tour on va l'emmener là j'en sors du
village pour soi un tour rapide comme ça
vous verrez tout va dès lors la pop sera
un petit tour
on sort ici derrière moi on laisse la
partie en cours de journée dans la zone
du village vous avez toutes les éloges
perrier peugeot mastercard rolex vous
empressez il ya plus encore ensuite on
emprunte le tunnel et on va arriver
ensuite dans la zone publique
si c'est une zone réservée monde peut
pas venir regard plein de choses
intéressantes à voir
vous avez notamment si vous regardez la
une stat miss ci est original ça déchire
et on va arriver ensuite dans la zone
publique
donc voilà vous avez le mur derrière
pour venir faire tous vos selphy
roland-garros qui est juste là suzanne
lenglen
c'est de l'autre côté par là bas voilà
comme ça que vous emmène un petit peu
dans les coulisses de roland garros je
regarde comment ça se passe et ça va pas
donc bon pou tout pas mal merci au coût
de me permettre de venir découvrir un
peu ça comme ça cette manière c'est
plutôt cool ça nous permet un petit peu
en même temps de venir faire un test de
smartphones côté photo dans des
conditions un petit peu exceptionnel ce
qu'on pourra pas tout le temps faire
j'aime bien est-ce que ça vous intéresse
comme ça qu'on puisse se poser parlait
justement bien d'un smartphone dans un
lieu à peu exceptionnel c'est plutôt
cool que au pot soit partenaire de dos
roland garros cette année donc bon c'est
le permet de faire tout ça eût-il été
ainsi
[Musique]
que de bach et franchement vous voulez
vous garder un petit match tranquille
avec l'étroitesse que vous n'êtes pas
mal utilisé jeep est en fait destinée
makhachkala
on va pas se mentir pour moi ce au port
et nous avec le zoom x 10 est vraiment
bien fait de très bonnes photos par
contre il ya un truc un peu trompeur
avec ce smartphone
non pas que la qualité soit pas au
rendez-vous qui soit menée toute
compagnie pas du tout par contre le nom
au port et nos zoom x 10 auront tendance
à penser qu'on assume optique x 10 alors
que pas du tout c'est un zoom hybride
faut dix on a un ou une fois cinq
options
ça s'est adjugé vendu ça marche mais
lorsque vous arrivez au x 6 carrément os
x 10 vous êtes en hybride et ce qui est
très marrant c'est que du point de vue
logiciel vous avez un parent fois un
photo normale x 3 ou une optique x 6
vous arrivez en hybride ils ont pu avoir
une étape supplémentaire avec un zoom x
5 et parfois si ce soit vraiment au
maximum de du zoom optique et non fois
ci sont nés en hybride alors après en
terme de perte de qualité je trouve que
ya pas de perte de qualité ça fonctionne
bien même jusqu'au x 10 nozomi hybride
fonctionne parfaitement bien on va pas
avoir la même précision que sur une fois
5 ou x 3 mais ça fonctionne parfaitement
bien par contre dès qu'on commence à
monter au delà du x 10 on va pas se
mentir
le rendu est vraiment pas terrible du
tout le x 20 c'est pas terrible
j'ai pas testé le x 60 parce que la
version g n'est pas équipé du zoom x 60
mais voyons déjà les restes du foie gras
j'imagine même pas ceux du x 60 votre
caméra principale
de 40 8 mégapixels c'est la sony mx 5
186 caméras qu'on a commencé à boire
depuis ce début d'année qui fonctionne
très bien qui équipent beaucoup de
smartphones du marché alors vous savez
ne suffit pas d'avoir une sony mx 5 186
pour avoir les mêmes qualités ça dépend
bien évidemment de votre lentilles ça va
dépendre du traitement logiciel derrière
et c'est vrai que en termes de
traitement logiciel au pot fait un
excellent boulot par contre ce qui est
assez intéressant à ce qui est rigolo
c'est que nativement on se dirait qu'on
va faire des photos en 48 mégapixels que
nenni nativement fait des photos en 12
mégapixels heures dans l'absolu c'est
pas bien grave et ça nous permettra
notamment sur les photos nuit de
profiter de la technologie 4 pixels en
euros vous allez prendre 4 pixels vous
allez les assembler ensemble à vous
faire un seul mais mes gros pixels un
gros pixels qui va capter plus de
lumière pour vous permettre d'avoir un
meilleur rendu en faible luminosité
et justement il ya aussi un gros
traitement logiciel derrière avec
l'ultra night mode luttera de might mode
se tuera dire ultralight mode version 2
le truc est bien le le rendu est
vraiment vraiment intéressant au rendez
vous c'est un gros boulot s'ils
voulaient se permet d'assembler pas mal
de choses d'avoir déjà une caméra qui
ouvre suffisamment pour capter beaucoup
de lumière l'a48 mégapixels avec les
quatre pixels en inde qu'il sortirait
une photo de 12 mégapixels plus le gros
traitement logiciel derrière qui est
fait de la part au pot plus l'autofocus
laser qui va tout de suite mieux vaut
faire le point extrêmement rapidement
c'est un ensemble de choses qui permet
de sortir des photos en faible
luminosité qui sont sans compromis la
stabilisation parlons-en
elle est vraiment top on a une petite
démonstration de l'apport au pôle ans
d'une présentation il ya quelques temps
où on voit effectivement autour de votre
appareil photo
vous êtes tout une petite stabilisation
est en fait vous n'avez pas une simple
stabilisation vous avez une double
stabilisation optique et on le voit très
clairement on se comprend le smartphone
qu'on à distance surtout moi qui a
tremblote ça ne bouge absolument pas ça
c'est vraiment très pratique et
lorsqu'ils ont des situations vous devez
shooter un peu rapidement vous a bougé
un peu c'est vraiment parfait au niveau
du grand angle c'est pareil le rendu est
cool vous avez un grand-angle de 120
degrés c'est pas forcément le truc que
vous avez utilisé le plus souvent mais
si vous voulez choper du monde sur une
photo de groupe
ça peut avoir un sens et bien évidemment
votre 13 mégapixels
en bas le zoom périscopique qui marche
bien qu'on a vu arriver notamment cette
année avec le web et 30 procès un truc
qui éprouvent rien qui marche aussi
extrêmement bien
permet d'avoir un des photos mais en
chercher très loin d'excellente qualité
enfin lorsque vous allez dire trop mais
dont je vous dis là qu'est tout de suite
il pas forcément au rendez vous mais
lorsque vous allez me résous mais avec
un x 6 mois x 10 ça fera parfaitement
bien faire parlant de la caméra de
cellfish l'aileron de requin puis pas si
vous avez suivi l'histoire
j'appuie ils nous annoncent 0.8 secondes
pour l'ouvrir bon c'est vrai que dans
l'absolu on pourrait se dire ah si je
veux utiliser faille sonnox ça va mettre
du temps c'est une certitude le côté
vous avez le capteur d'empreintes
digitales sous l'écran qui va
parfaitement bien ça on en reparlera
lorsque j'ai fait le test complet du
smartphone hors parti photos et ce qui
est cool c'est que les smartphones shut
up
voyez la caméra rentrer vous avez un
petit message qui s'affiche
qui vous a dit que le smartphone a chuté
du fait d'avoir cette recette appareil
photo qui va s'ouvrir comme ça c'est un
smartphone qui n'a pas de certification
ip pas certifié contre l'eau et la
poussière
néanmoins une fois fermé je suis
persuadé que le smartphone viendra pas
tout comme ce qu'on a pu avoir sur le
point de plus cette pro
deux salles deux ambiances voilà on se
met bien on se met à l'aise deux salles
deux ambiances on continue à parler duo
pourrait note le fonds sauf que cette
fois ci je voulais vous parler de la
partie photo de nuit et je le fais dans
un endroit où il fait nuit ou quatre s'y
prête
on est parti pendant trois jours au
hellfest vip cette année je me suis dit
ben c'est bien passé de roland-garros au
hellfest fossat quand même plutôt cool
donc pour la partie photo nue vous
emmène au hellfest
ce qu'on fait c'est que on va se faire
défiler les clichés va être plein de
photos le modèle que j'ai là par contre
cette fois ci est équipé d'un zoom x 60
j'ai fait à des photos en outre 60 jours
bon voilà c'est vraiment histoire
d'aller chercher deux fois 60 parce que
sinon temps globalement aucun intérêt
témoin les qualités et pas terrible du
tout il ya toutes les photos grand temps
où il ya plein de choses prison elle
fait cela nuit je vous laisse regarder
moi personnellement je trouve ça
vraiment bien je suis assez conquis
alors vous me direz sur un festival
comme ça il ya aussi beaucoup de lumière
oui mais pas tout le temps pas que le
truc est assez polyvalent fait des
belles photos la nuit intéressant je
vous dis une fois de plus aux artichauts
zoom x 10 des vous montez au delà c'est
pas terrible ce un peu rigolo mais pas
tellement bon coéquiper des fessiers
l'amitié voilà il m'a fatigué il se
réveille il se réveille et je vous donne
rendez-vous d'ici deux jours pour
justement la vidéo du hellfest le
débrief 2019 toute notre histoire mais
c'est aussi très passionnant
[Musique]
un peu ce qui va ce premier acte ce
smartphone c'est que toutes vos caméras
vont travailler de concert pour vous
donner une image complètement optimisé
donc ça c'est plutôt cool c'est pas
juste une caméra qui fait ça puis
l'autre qui prend le relais elles
travaillent toutes ensemble pour permet
d'avoir un rendu qui est parfait ou à
quelque chose qui est en tout cas c'est
un très bon paquet fait en avant par au
pot c'est peut-être le smartphone qui
manquait du côté chien au pot pour aller
vraiment chercher huawei du côté de la
photo justement avec saisonniers preuve
c'est parce que vous en pensez dites moi
tout ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce que il peut vous
bottez est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
intéressant est ce que vous trouvez que
au pot va dans le bon sens et puis
qu'est-ce que vous pensez petite journée
à roland garros je vous le dis tout ça
on va aux commentaires donnent rendez
vous dès demain